hi everybody it's pete holmes from the
pete home show i am so excited to
announce the winner of the pete holm
show fan art contest so many wonderful
submissions so many wonderful artists
out there thank you for all of them it
was very very difficult to choose who
would be winning this amazing piece of
street art by our friend skyler gray so
uh it was hard to pick but looking at
them all and you know really meditating
on it and drinking heavily we went with
blake loosely for this picture that he
did of me as a camp counselor if you
look closely at the clipboard there's so
many inside references to my podcast my
stand up and the show but blake above
all you're an amazing artist so thank
you so much please enjoy the skylar gray
in return it's like a hippie communion
art traded for art weed bro and i sleep
on a hollowed-out school bus man with my
wife moon sun
i love hippies if you want to see more
of the fan art go to petehomes.com and
in the meantime please watch the beat
home show midnight after conan on tbs